- - À notre panel ce soir, on
acaccueille Stéphanie, Michel C.
AuAuger, bonsoir à vous trois.
OnOn va commencer en parlant de
cecette sixième vague qui seraià
poporte-fort malheureusement pae
ququ'il y a pas tellement de ges
ququi ont l'appétit pourra-t-on
paparler de COVID, mais les
chchiffres sont en hausse, les
trtravers de la santé sont de ps
enen plus nombreux à être absen,
vovous avez entendu notre entree
avavec M. Docteur Veillette.
IlIl n'a pas fait de mesures
susupplémentaires ou de dire fae
cececi ou cela, il relance la
reresponsabilité individuelle.
StStéphanie, je vais commencer
avavec vous, les gens n'ont plus
enenvie d'entendre parler de COD
esest-ce que ces appels à la
prprudence-là sont entendus?
- - Je ne suis pas convaincu pae
quque la plupart des mesures sot
didisparus puis on a un peu
tétélégraphié le retrait du mase
enen disant que ce sera pour la
mimi-avril. On voit que les gens
auau Québec se disent que quand
totout ça vague disparu, on va
ararrêter de suivre les règles.8
% % des Québécois disent qu'on
cocontinuera de porter le masque
unune fois que ce ne sera plus
obobligatoire intérieur. On ne
pepeut pas imaginer que c'est ue
grgrosse adhésion pour le masqu.
SiSi on finit pareil tout seul à
lele porter...
- - peut-être qu'on aura le pois
dudu regard.
- - C'est important parce que au
QuQuébec, c'est chez nous que
cecette proportion là est la pls
fafaible plus qu'un Alberta ou u
CaCanada. Il faut espérer que la
cacampagne de sensibilisation ùu
onon dit aux gens qu'il faut
apapprendre à vivre avec le vir,
ququ'elle soit plus respectée
paparce que pour l'instant, les
sisignes qu'on a ne sont pas s'é
fafait la.
- - Michel, pourquoi ce point de
prpresse hier avec Michel Boileu
ququi n'a pas fait d'annonce?
- - Je pense qu'il voulait
sisincèrement dire : écouter et
fafait attention, ce n'est pas
fifini. Mais ce n'est pas ce que
leles gens ont nécessairement
cocompris. Les gens ne comprennt
papas nécessairement qu'on doit
cocontinuer à faire attention,
cocontinuer à porter le même
ininstant que le virus circule.
LeLes gens oublient la traductin
dedeux ans laissent tomber les
memesures est visible avec le
vivirus, ce n'est pas la même
chchose. Je pense quque Docteur
BoBoileau essaya de bonne foi de
didire qu'on avait encore un
prproblème qu'il y aurait
prprobablement une sixième vagu.
JeJe ne suis pas sûr que son
memessage a été bien compris.
- - Stéphanie Chouinard,
mamaintenant, il ne doit pas avr
bebeaucoup d'appétit pour les
gogouvernements de mettre en ple
dedes mesures, et c'est vrai por
leles provinces qui basculent en
anannée électorale?
- - C'est vrai pour en Ontario n
l'l'a vu au courant du mois de
mamars le ministre Ford s'est
dédébarrassé plus rapidement que
ceceux à quoi on s'attendait des
memesures sanitaires. Même qu'on
n'n'en parle pas encore, mais il
sesemblerait qu'il y ait une
sisixième vague nano porte. Et e
prproblème en Ontario actuellemt
etet quand... pour vous donner n
élélément de comparaison, au pls
fofort de la cinquième vague en
OnOntario, on test elle était
spspéciale 75 000... les chiffrs
ofofficiels sont loin de la
réréalité, ce qui nous indique
ququ'on est loin de la réalité,
c'c'est aussi ce les tests dans
leles grandes villes comme Ottaa
ouou Toronto où on démontre que
dadans plusieurs quartiers, les
afaffections sont en hausse.
- - C'est un outil qu'on a plu à
QuQuébec et qu'on va sans doute
rerelancer, le dépistage des eax
ususées, que bien des experts
coconseillaient, il reste que me
sisi jamais la vague montait, il
vava falloir à un moment donné
ququ'il y a des consignes un peu
plplus dures, peut-être qu'on va
êêtre obligées de renforcer les
chchoses, ceci dit, dans une ane
élélectorale, c'est un peu comme
fafait du aime et dénonce les
memesure...
- - en plus, avec la loi, on a
lalaissé tomber les lois qui
pepermettaient d'agir par décre.
OnOn dit qu'on ne remettra pas e
memesures opérationnelles, donc,
ilils vont être vraiment coincés
sisi l'écart remonte à un point
tetel qu'on voit les hôpitaux
dédébordés, qu'on voit le nombre
dede décès. C'est surtout les ps
vuvulnérables que les personnes
ââgées, celles qui ont des
mamaladies chroniques auquel il
fafaut faire attention. On ne
vovoudrait pas qu'il y a une méa
cocombe encore. On n'est pas reu
lala, une hécatombe...
l'l'été arrive, le printemps, on
esespère que ce sera moins pire.
CÇa laisse peu de marge de
mamanoeuvre au gouvernement.
- - Ce qui a aussi attiré
l'l'attention aujourd'hui, fin e
lala saga peut-être sur le
remplacement de la flotte des
didieux avions de l'armée
cacanadienne, des amis violents
ququi ont maintenant 40 ans et i
sosont vulnérables pour des avis
dede chasse, est-ce que vous
pepensez vraiment... le
gogouvernement Trudeau se tourne
vevers les F 35, on a mis de
l'l'argent là-dessus, entamer ds
nénégociations, est-ce qu'on va
vevers la fin de la saga?
- - C'est pas parce qu'on arrive
prprès du but qu'on y est tout à
fafait. Même si les négociations
ababoutissent, les premiers avis
nene seront pas livrés avant 20.
OnOn ne peut pas dire qu'on
paparticipera à une nouvelle
mimission de l'OTAN demain matin
avavec ses avions la. L'élément
prprincipal va ici une partie de
seses 19 milliards de dollars-là
seseront dépensés au Canada, une
papartie de cette flotte sera
coconstruite en sol canadien.
LoLorsqu'on parle d'enjeux
d'd'approvisionnement pour les
foforces canadiennes, l'économie
cacanadienne va bénéficier, mais
popour le moment elles ne sont s
enen mesure d'offrir cette
gagarantie va au gouvernement.
C'C'est vraiment le dernier poit
d'd'achèvement.
- - Ce ne sont pas les mêmes
avavions que le gouvernement
lilibéral avait promis de ne pas
acacheter, et c'était ce qui étt
vivisé au départ par le
gogouvernement Harper?
- - Il y avait de la controverse
auautour de ses avions la, le
momoteur ne fonctionnait pas bi,
onon les comparait à des cerfs-
vovolants pour les moteurs.
StStéphanie a raison, on commene
lala vraie affaire qui est
reretombée une fois qu'on a dit
cecela, un deuxième débat va
s's'engager... j'étais à Ottawa
ququand on a acheté les avions
acactuels il y a très longtemps
lolors de la première campagne n
8080 et il y avait des députés
lilibéraux, fédéralistes et tous
ququi se déchire à la chemise en
didisant que si le Québec n'a ps
sasa part de retombée... ce n'et
papas pertinent pour le Québec-.
C'C'est pour vous donner une ide
dede ce que peut se faire un dét
susur où vont aller les retombé.
- - Finalement il y a des écueis
popolitiques derrière ça?
- - C'est toujours un sujet de
dédébat, évidemment. Les
gogouvernements Gérés les uns
apaprès les autres la question s
dédépenses militaires. Ça a
totoujours été malheureusement e
blblague tant pour les sous-
mamarins... on a dépensé dans ls
dédépenses militaires comme tous
leles pays du monde depuis 35 a.
LaLa part des dépenses militairs
papar rapport du PIB a fondu de
momoitié à peu près partout sura
plplanète et le Canada encore
plplus. Probablement qu'on va ds
lele prochain budget avoir une
lelecture là-dessus à savoir es-
cece qu'on va remonter les
dédépenses militaires au niveaue
cece que l'OTAN aimerait voir? n
a a déjà des indications dans ce
sesens-là. Il y a d'autres
dedemandes, on parle des avionse
chchasse, mais il y a aussi la
chchaîne radar des avions s de
chchasse, tout ça tombe un peu n
ruruine. Avec la guerre en
UkUkraine, évidemment, on réalie
ququ'on a un voisin qui s'appele
lala Russie. Ça ne veut pas dire
ququ'ils vont nous envahir deman
mamatin, mais il y a quand mêmee
plplus en plus d'exploration por
leles ressources naturelles en
ArArctique et si on n'est pas là
popour faire valoir nos droits,a
pepeut causer problème.
- - Ça a changé la perception de
cece que ça veut dire de
rerenouveler ses capacités
d'd'armement Canada, avec ce
coconflit en Ukraine, on se rend
cocompte que les choses peuvent
babasculer, on s'en rend compte
popour la perception du public.
PaParlons d'Ontario, ils viennet
dede signer l'entente aujourd'h,
bibien sûr les parents voient qe
leles grands gagnants parce quea
cocoûte cher que les frais de
gagarderie en Ontario, mais
StStéphanie Chouinard, sur le pn
popolitique, est-ce que les deux
prpremiers ministres Trudeau et
onontariens sont tous les deux
gagagnants?
- - C'est certain que pour
MoMonsieur Trudeau, lors du dépt
dudu budget il y a un an on état
totous... est-ce que le
gogouvernement pourra signer avc
trtrois provinces. Finalement, a
étété ou en Ontario c'était le
plplus cher au pays. C'est riene
momoins qu'une révolution des
poportefeuilles des familles qui
vava avoir lieu dans les
prprochaines années. Mais pour
MoMonsieur Ford, c'est aussi une
pepetite victoire parce qu'il
ététait... il espérait avoir un
pepeu plus que ce qu'il avait éé
mimis sur la table année dernièe
onon a 3 milliards
susupplémentaires, une année
susupplémentaire de financemente
lala part du gouvernement fédér.
IlIl faut voir que cette entente
llà arrive vraiment à la 11e
heheure parce que si l'enfant
n'n'est pas signé au premier
avril, il y a une partie de ces
fofonds-là qui disparaissaient.e
meme demande si les parents
d'd'Ontario vont s'en souvenir u
jojour des élections à savoir de
rérécompenser Monsieur Ford à
trtrouver un terrain d'entente
avavec Monsieur Trudeau aussi on
vava le punir de nous avoir fait
atattendre si longtemps.
- - Michel?
- - Monsieur Trudeau n'avait pas
lele choix parce qu'il ne peut s
alaller en campagne e électoral.
ilil ne pouvait pas aller là en
didisant que toutes les autres
prprovinces, tous les autres
teterritoires vous enseignez en
babas de la feuille, vous, vouse
l'l'avez pas fait Monsieur Ford
popourquoi? Il y avait une étude
dede la Banque Scotia l'année
papassée qui disait que les fras
dede garde en Ontario étaient sr
lele point de devenir... le poit
dudu budget des logements. Pour
çaça, Monsieur Trudeau remporte
ququand même une aussi grande
vivictoire parce que c'est ce qe
leles libéraux voulaient faire
dedepuis longtemps. Ils avaient
nénégocié avec toutes les
prprovinces justes avant d'être
babattu... c'est quelque chose i
esest dans le programme libéral
dedepuis longtemps.
- - Je vais vérifier s'il me ree
enencore du temps, oui, il me
rereste une minute. Un Tweet qua
ététonné beaucoup de gens de Jan
KeKenney de la giffle de Will
SmSmith. Et la relie à toutes cs
popolitiques environnementales i
totouchent autour du pétrole.
RéRéaction là-dessus?
- - Je pense que c'est un
paparallèle qui est extrêmement
dodouteux, je ne vois pas pourqi
onon référait à un humain un
évévénement malheureux comme cei
dedes Oscars hier. L'académie a
cocondamné ce geste, je trouve e
c'c'est mal fait de récupérer ca
dede cette façon-là.
- - On a l'impression que c'estn
pepetit gars de 12 ans qui est
dederrière le tweet de Monsieur
KeKenny. C'est indigne d'un
gogouvernement provincia